diferente de la derecha
también la ex presidenta del senado eva
copa ha desafiado al ex presidente evo
morales al postular por su cuenta a la
alcaldía de el alto el movimiento al
socialismo la expulsó por no aceptar a
otro candidato sin embargo las encuestas
pronostican un triunfo aplastante de
copa lo que supondría una ruptura de
fondo en el oficialismo
noto
a la derecha del espectro político están
el ex ministro de la presidenta jeanine
áñez iván arias como favorito para ganar
la alcaldía de la paz y manfred reyes
villa que se impondría en la de
cochabamba en santa cruz el periodista y
candidato centrista gar yáñez encabeza
las preferencias si se confirman los
pronósticos las cuatro capitales más
pobladas elegirían a opositores como
alcaldes dos verdes
son diversas oposiciones ahora cada una
tiene objetivos absolutamente distintos
probablemente algunas de las oposiciones
políticas al más en el objetivo de
reencaminar el proceso de cambio
político en el país pero hay otras que
quieren por supuesto destruirlo o sea
quieren dejarlo atrás tras los 14 años
del gobierno de evo morales hasta su
salida del poder bajo presión en
noviembre de 2019 y la contundente
victoria de luis arce en las elecciones
presidenciales los masistas no esperaban
tanta incertidumbre y desafíos en los
comicios regionales y municipales